NOW AND THEN.
LIVE THERE IN TAIPEI, WILL
RIPLEY GOOD TO SEE YOU, THANK
YOU FOR THE UPDATE.
I WANT TO GO TO ANNA WHO'S
PROPOSING ISLAND TO NIVEA.
OH THIS REALLY IS A CASE
NUMBER.
THEY'RE HURTING FRESH RECORDS,
AND THAT'S NO GOOD NEWS.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THIS IS A DOUBLE BLOW TO INDIA.
CERTAINLY, THE WEST COAST THAT
HAS BEEN HIT BY THIS CYCLONE.
THE 4 STATES THAT HAVE BEEN
HEAVILY IMPACTED, WITH HEAVY
RAIN, AND EXTENSIVE FLOODING.
HIGH WINDS.
EVEN THOUGH I'M PRETTY YOUNG
MILLS THAT THE CLEANUP IS
ONGOING, THE FLOODING IS
ONGOING, IT'S GOING TO TAKE,
MANY DAYS IF NOT LONGER TO
RETURN TO NORMAL.
THINGS LIKE THE VACCINATION
PROGRAM, THAT WAS BEING RULED
OUT, CAN ACTUALLY RESUME.
EVERYONE HAS BEEN SUSPENDED
WITHOUT THE CUSHION.
HOW CAN YOU SAY THAT IT'S.
WE'VE SEEN CASE NUMBERS COMING
DOWN, PARTICULARLY IN THIS AREA.
BUT, WITH HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE BEING EVACUATED, FROM
LOW LYING AREAS, AND MOVE TO
SHELTERS, AND EVACUATION
CENTERS, BEING CRAMMED
TOGETHER.
THIS IS GIVING AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR COVID TO JUST SPREAD AGAIN.
FROM CLUSTERS TO FORM.
COVID PATIENTS BEING REMOVED
FROM MODERATE HEAT, AND LOW
LYING AREAS.
THEIR LIVES VERY MUCH PUT A
RISK.
THE INDIAN AIR FORCE IS ON
STANDBY, THE PRIME MINISTER, HE
IS ACROSS EVERYTHING THAT IS
TAKING PLACE AT THE MOMENT.
THE CURRENT DEATH TOLL, AS IT
STANDS, IS 213 BUT, HAVING
MOVED ALL THOSE WHO OWN LAND
PEOPLE.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN IN
INDIA'S HAVE A MOMENT OF REPLAY,
I HOPE, IN RECENT YEARS, THE
MAZE WE TEAM UP THE HIGH DEATH
TOLLS, I SHOULD MENTION AS WELL,
THERE IS ONE OF THE LITTLE BABY
AS WE SPEAK AND LOTS OF PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN RESCUED.
THEY WERE OFFERED FUEL, FUELED
A THRIFT OF THE CONDITIONS,
THEY UNDERSTAND WITH THEIR JULY
TO EARTH.
THEY'RE SAYING, I WANT TO GET
HELICOPTERS IN THE SKIES, BUT
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE
PICTURES, CONDITIONS ARE
HORRENDOUS.
SO, WE DON'T KNOW WHEN THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO GET THOSE
HELICOPTERS IN.
ROBIN?
>> IT DOESN'T LOOK GREAT, NO.
ANNA COREN, THANK YOU FOR THAT
REPORT.
I WANT TO TALK MORE ABOUT THAT,
WHETHER IT'S PEDRAM, OR WHETHER
HE JOINS ME NOW FOR MORE ON
THAT CYCLONE, HAMPERING INDIA'S
COVID RELIEF EFFORTS.
JUST TALK US THROUGH WHAT IS
HITTING THE WEST COAST THERE?
HI PATRICK.
>> STILL, NO STORM SYSTEM.
GREAT SEEING THE UAE COME TO
THIS MANUFACTURE, WE KNOW IT'S
THE STRONGEST EVER WASTED.
STRONGER SUDDEN, HIS STRONGEST
ACROSS THE AREA, IT WILL BE
MAKE IN FACE LAND OR IF IT HAD
TO THE EQUIVALENT OF A CATEGORY
3, NEAR CATEGORY 4 IF THAT
WOULD WORK.
OCEAN, KIND OF SPEAKS TO HOW
YOU WOULD THINK ABOUT THIS IS A
WEIRD WAY.
OKAY, OUT FOR 125 KILOMETERS AN
HOUR TO OVERREACT HER.
HAVE A NEW RACE FOR MUMBAI,
STRETCHING AS FAR NORTH INTO A
LOT OF BUYER.
YOU'LL KNOW, SHE UNDERSTANDS
350 MILLIMETERS HAVE COME DOWN
IN THE LAST 24 HOURS.
KEEP IN MIND, THIS IS THE
CATALYST THAT DRIVES HIM.
YOU CAN TAKE IN THE FIRST 5
MONTHS OF 2021, PUT THEM
TOGETHER, AND VIDEO RANGED FAR
EXCEED, KNOW THE 3 IS NOT THE
CDC AND HOW MUCH IS HOW MUCH
THE SLOWLY COURAGE WAS GOING TO.
BECAUSE AS SOON AS THE WINDS
DIE DOWN THE 24 HOURS, THEY
BECOME DISGUSTING.
THE AMOUNT OF RAINFALL, REALLY
ACROSS THIS REGION TO, AND MAKE
YOUR SHOW, WE ARE WATCHING
AREAS JUST WATCH OF THE AREA,
WHERE THE CENTER OF THE STORE
WILL BE.
GUSTY WIND, MAYBE 70, OR 80
KILOMETERS AN HOUR.
EVENTUALLY, THE WIND DIES DOWN,
AND BECOMES, PRIMARILY, A RAIN
ELEMENT FOR THE STORY HERE.
RAINFALL AMOUNTS, REALLY, AS
STRESSFUL AS THEY COME.
150 MILLIMETERS, PUSHING TO 200
MILLIMETERS.
LOOK AT NEW DELHI.
I'VE LOOKED INTO THIS, THEY'VE
ONLY PICKED UP 22 MILLIMETERS
OF RAINFALL, AND ALL OF 2021.
THEY CAN PICK UP 200
MILLIMETERS HERE, OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL DAYS IF, THIS SYSTEM
CONTINUES TO TRACK, FARTHER
TOWARDS THE NORTH, AND THEY'VE
BEEN ABLE TO CANCEL MY SYLVIA.
AND YOU KNOW THE INSTRUCTIONS,
GIVEN THE PANDEMIC, ALL THAT IS
PASSED, NO VIEW.
>> THAT REALLY IS A DELUGE.